game on this is Club grade open football
for women in Sydney
Annika lindhardt has played for 16 years
and now runs this tournament she like
the rest of the players in this
competition will be in the audience when
Australia and New Zealand co-host the
Women's World Cup next year
so cool to be able to host like a full
women's International Tournament on home
soil I already have tickets we're all
kind of geared up to go and ready and
it's gonna be really cool to get to
support the matildas and for them to
kind of have the Home Advantage there so
yeah I'm super excited
since the last Women's World Cup in 2019
audience numbers have seen significant
growth with more than 365 million people
tuning into the Euro women's football
final this year
the commercial value of the women's game
is also gaining strength off the pitch
with a surge in sponsorship and
broadcast rights up for negotiation for
the first time
so we're starting to see unbundled media
rights and broadcast rights programs
with previously you would have for
example a women's world cup and a men's
World Cup the broadcast rights tied
together but the 2023 Women's World Cup
is going to be the first has the two of
them separated so that we can really get
a sense of the commercial value of the
women's game as a standalone product the
host Nations Australia and New Zealand
Grassroots support continues to grow and
both countries have introduced equal pay
between the men's and women's teams at a
senior National level but on a global
scale pies money and pay lags behind the
men's game including at the World Cup
level
while the prize pot has risen tournament
on tournament it still pales in
comparison to the men's
the short answer to that is yes there is
a long way to go I mean there's still
enormous disparity for instance between
the very top Elite women footballers and
the very top Elite men but of course the
counter argument to that is there's also
a difference in in Revenue
that hasn't deterred the players 32
Nations will compete for the Women's
World Cup title with Australian
supporters hoping their national team
the matildas will have a home advantage
I think Australia can win for sure I
hope so
um they're a really strong team they've
shown some really good results uh
particularly recently
the Women's World Cup kicks off in July
next year Sarah Clark Al Jazeera
Brisbane Australia